une salle comble des applaudissements et
l'air satisfait du devoir accompli
l'un des ministres du gouvernement
d'abdelhamid babe à tout sourire le
nouveau premier ministre libyen
optimiste pour l'avenir
je jure devant dieu de m'acquitter de
mes fonctions en toute honnêteté et
loyauté de rester toujours fidèle aux
objectifs de la révolution du 17 février
de respecter la constitution et la
déclaration constitutionnelle est de
protéger les intérêts du peuple libyen
bon c'est les plaies de la révolution
qui a entraîné la chute de muamar
kadhafi et plonger la libye dans le
chaos
dix ans plus tard sous l'oeil
d'émissaires de l'onu et de l'union
européenne le nouveau gouvernement a
donc pour mission de gérer les
institutions et d'assurer la transition
d'ici de nouvelles élections le 24
décembre 2021 neuf mois pour travailler
et répondre aux attentes immenses des
libyens la priorité est de s'occuper des
besoins et des conditions de vie
difficiles du citoyen comme le manque de
liquidités les coupures d'électricité et
l'épidémie du coronavirus mais on
souhaite au gouvernement de réussir dans
sa mission et on espère qu'il aidera le
peuple libyen et on souhaite la
prospérité au peuple libyen
on espère que la libye va se rassembler
sous un gouvernement d'unité et que la
première initiative du gouvernement sera
la réconciliation nationale beaucoup
d'espoir envers ce gouvernement suscité
par l'onu le 23 octobre 2020 à genève
les deux principales entités du pays ont
signé un cessez le feu général et
permanent
d'un côté le gouvernement d'union
nationale le gn a de l'autre les forces
du maréchal khalifa haftar basée à l'est
du pays et notamment benghazi berceau de
la révolution le 5 février 2021
la liste de l'ingénieur et outsider
abdelhamid ben hiba était donc
plébiscité au cours du forum du dialogue
politique libyen réunis en suisse
ils ont une grande responsabilité et ils
vont de l'avant
nous examinerons le déroulement des
opérations parce que soyons vraiment
clair l'objectif est d'organiser des
élections nationales
l'équipe d'abdelhamid bay bar a donc
obtenu mercredi 10 mars la confiance du
parlement
depuis le premier ministre s'est
notamment déplacer dans la ville de
syrte
meurtri par les combats et a inauguré
une conférence pour la lutte contre le
coronavirus un nouveau gouvernement
attendu aussi sur le départ des 20 mille
mercenaires et combattants étrangers
toujours présents dans le pays
[Applaudissements]